officials in pakistan say flash floods
across much of the country have killed
over a thousand people and displaced
thousands more since mid-june
the newest fatalities are primarily
being reported in the northwest and down
in southern sin province
weeks of unrelenting monsoon rains have
affected more than 30 million people and
have wreaked havoc on vital
infrastructure
a national emergency is in force and the
country's prime minister is appealing to
other countries for help
they built their home with their own
hands
now these two brothers are clearing up
what remains of it
i'll have to ask the government for help
rebuilding the house
otherwise
i have no hope
i worked day and night to build this
home i sacrificed my sleep for it we
took out a loan that we haven't yet paid
off
the government is promising financial
aid for the families forced to leave
their homes
but it's a mammoth task
the authorities say more than 30 million
people
are affected
my neighbors children were swept away by
the floods we've all suffered great
losses the water is three to six meters
high
prime minister shaiba sharif inspected
the damage in some of the worst hit
areas and dropped relief packages for
people
his government is calling it a
humanitarian disaster caused by climate
change
but opponents say corruption and poor
planning have made a bad situation
worse
and for more let's bring in adil shiraz
a county country i should say director
for the charity care international in
pakistan adil sharaz pakistan has called
for international help no surprise when
you look at the images that we've been
seeing for the past few hours
what's needed most
so first of all like i mean if you see
the
damages which has happened approximately
33 million people are affected out of
that which is a huge population and
it is in all across the country
balochistan and provinces are hard hit
and then
kpk and southern punjab is equally hit
also by the uh by the flood
at this stage shelter is the most needed
which is temporary shelter for these
people who have been affected
um items like ministerial hygiene kits
for women and girls that is required
clean water supplies are needed at
different level
food and non-food items especially like
cooking pots mosquito nets
and then sleeping mats and other
essential items as part of the non-food
item kits are required food both in the
shape of cooked and uncooked meals are
needed at the
field level
and then uh i think to be honest it's
not an emergency where
it will end with the life-saving support
which will happen at the initial stage
it should require a lot of support in
early recovery towards long-term
development planning
what i'm hearing is all the basic things
one needs for basic subsistence
what are the kinds of stories the
challenges you're hearing most often
from from
individual pakistanis
when you speak with the people who have
been affected from this flood you really
see that
they
their houses are damaged they don't have
a shelter they are living under the sky
and the flooding and rain still
continues so to be honest like the
situation is becoming worse and worse
every day
and the rains haven't stopped uh the
predictions still say it will rain a
couple of more days and more water is
coming so let me ask you this
i'm going to interrupt just by asking
you this because you made it very clear
for me how critical is the situation
right now in other words how long can
you wait for help before things become
even more dire
everything is required to be honest
today if we don't help today there will
be more and more challenges we'll be
facing in coming days to come so
international health are required from
now and
all the aid workers are at the field
level responding to this emergency along
with the government of pakistan so the
support is to be honest required now now
if we if we really wait for a long time
we'll be late for this response so we
really need to think of today rather
than tomorrow
today rather than tomorrow that is adil
shiraz country director for care
international in pakistan many thanks
sir
thank you so much